bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on a parlé
d' emmanuel macron devant le parlement
européen aujourd'hui le parle le
parlement le président qui va devoir
répondre aux questions des eurodéputés
un grand oral qui aurait des allures de
discours de campagne est ce que c'est
votre avis pierre frédéric billets
oui on voit bien la manipulation le
président même accro à la chance de
pouvoir devenir président heureux les
européennes dans six mois à l'occasion
du début de campagne présidentielle et
c'est une grande chance pour lui on voit
bien il va l'utiliser a plein on le sent
bien on a bien vu l'utilisation du
drapeau européen sous l'arc de triomphe
retirer très rapidement soit disant
prévu pour trois jours on voit bien que
les macro ont utilisé la plains cette
présidence bon j'espère que deux
français seront pas dupes de cette
petite manipulation oui donc en fait son
discours il va falloir lire entre les
lignes et voir les messages de campagne
qui s'y cachent c'est votre avis aussi
alexander nikolic
oui bien sûr arriva il va présenter sa
vision aussi de l'union européenne c'est
de se donner une
une stature une stature européenne
mais
en fait on peut quand même se dire que
depuis depuis cinq ans depuis qu'ils
nous avaient dit que il veut donner une
autre vision pour pour lieu
ni bien rien n'a changé parce qu'il a
jamais eu une influence qu'il a voulu se
se donner et ce qu'on constate surtout
c'est que l'union européenne quand il
n'a absolument pas changé sur sur
l'essentiel on voit qu'elle est toujours
aussi impuissante dans la crise
ukrainienne actuellement on voit qu'elle
est toujours un put aussi impuissant
pour réindustrialiser le pays et essayer
de nous faire croire que par ce biais là
la france ait lieu seront épuisantes ca9
évidemment ça fonctionne pas et
et je pense que ça changera rien avec la
présidence évidemment de maquereaux même
si l'exécutif n'a pas forcément de marge
de manoeuvre en tout cas c'est pas
forcément tapis rouge pour pour emmanuel
macron il ya yannick jadot d'ailleurs
qu'il l'attend au tournant dans
l'hémicycle il va devoir répondre aux
questions des eurodéputés et il n'est
pas le seul est ce que vous vous
souvenez d'ailleurs de cette séquence à
strasbourg c'était avant la crise
sanitaire en avril 2008 emmanuel ma
comprenez pour la première fois la
parole devant le parlement et il a été
interpellé par un eurodéputé belge
regardez
monsieur le président un livre vous dit
philosophe
il affirme qu'aucun de vos mots n'est le
fruit du hasard
voici quelques mois vous avez parlé des
gens qui réussissent et des gens qui ne
sont rien vous n'avez pas dit des gens
qui ne font rien ou des gens qui n'ont
rien vous avez parlé des gens qui ne
sont rien voyez vous pour nous le projet
européen consiste précisément à faire en
sorte que plus jamais on aucun endroit
de ce continent pour qu'une femme aucun
homme ne puisse être considérée comme
rien ou se penser comme rien qu'à
reconsidérer des êtres humains comme
rien c'est permettre de leur faire subir
n'importe quoi et cela nous ne le ferons
jamais monsieur le président vous avez
pris coutume d'offrir à vos hôtes de
marque un cadeau permettez moi de faire
de même je vous offre
cette corde escalade symbole de la corde
et à laquelle vous semblez tenir
alors voilà on s'en souvient ça fait est
que je me suis permise de choisir cet
extrait parce que ça fait écho aux
propos récents d'emmanuel macron contre
contre les non vaccinés pierre frédéric
billet ce n'est pas simple le président
va devoir aussi faire face aux attaques
des eurodéputés non
oui et les eurodéputés savez ils ont une
vision de la france qui est qui et
extérieur
et puis le président maintenant c'est un
marqueur de sa personnalité on voit bien
qu'il a une sorte de mépris récurrent
pour les plus faibles les français on
voit là il va emmerder les non vaccinés
il faut traverser la rue pour trouver un
job vous savez quand on est présent dans
le public il faut savoir rassembler les
français il faut pas diviser les
français il faut surtout pas mépriser
les français vous savez les gens ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent avec leurs moyens
leurs compétences leur courage
en tant que maire de dreux moi j'essaye
de rassembler de tous les gens de
renvoyer qu'on essaie de trouver un
destin commun et c'est pas en
stigmatisant des gens du doigt en disant
qu'ils ont mauvais prix donc ils n'ont
pas le bon comportement qui n'ont pas
les bonnes études qu'ils ont pas la
bonne maison quand on va y arriver il
faut essayer de tracer un destin commun
et d'embarquer tout le monde dans ce
destin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alexander nicoli fait ce que le
président a changé est ce qu il se
souvient selon vous de cette séquence
est ce qu'il aura en tête lors de son
discours
je pense évidemment qu'il n'a pas changé
au regard des dernières déclarations et
mépris qui peut avoir ou qu'ils
expriment manière très directe
évidemment avec ses mots sur sur la
volonté de d'emmerder les
les non vaccinés la forme et la
communication compte aussi pour l'image
du pays
et c'est assez représentatif quand on
voit d'autres parlementaires européens à
voir cette image là de de la france mais
je pense que tout ça c'est des voix là
c'est vraiment de la communication est
vraiment ce qui est intéressant avec la
présidence des manuels macron l'union
européenne ça va vraiment être
ça va vraiment être quelle vision on
aura aussi de cette union européenne je
rappelle que le président essaie
constitutionnel doit être le garant de
l'indépendance nationale est ce que il
ya toujours cette volonté de faire
exister une france indépendante est ce
que il ya la volonté
de redonner à la france vraiment une une
grande puissance encore une fois est-ce
que quelle vision namur est ce que c'est
juste un marché avec des consommateurs
ou est ce qu'il ya une identité
historique est ce qu'il ya encore des
identités nationales d identité qui nous
rassemble tous en europe vincee des
enjeux à mon avis qui dépasse le
commentaire et savoir quelle quelle
image peuvent avoir les autres
parlementaires précisément des manuels
macron momentanément tout ça c'est c'est
bon je pense dans l'histoire de l'europe
et de la france et du sexe cette
élection sera importante
très très très secondaire mais on veut
être patronne marine le pen a déjà pris
les devants 1
signe que ce grand oral est évidemment
fera partie de la campagne
présidentielle
voyez ce qu'a dit marine le pen hier sur
cette présidence française
contrairement à ce qu'ils veulent bien
nous faire croire voir croire lui-même
emmanuel macron n'est nullement l'un des
grands leaders de l'union européenne
tout comme son prédécesseur il est resté
pendant quatre ans le factotum de madame
merkel le factotum on le voit bien à la
campagne a déjà commencé
oui
vous avez bien sûr et je l'expliqué sa
fin on voit que la la voix de la france
ne peut pas compter sur plein de sujets
par exemple si on parle d'écologie on a
en france un mix énergétique
nucléaire hydraulique qui nous permet
d'avoir une énergie plus propre qui émet
moins de gaz à effet de serre et plus
économique on voit aujourd'hui que
l'union européenne a choisi d'autres
voies pour désigner quels sont les
énergies propres et ou est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des investissements c'est à dire
par exemple les éoliennes le
photovoltaïque notamment les énergies
renouvelables et c'est évidemment pas
dans l'intérêt de la france qui était un
leader dans d'autres dans d'autres
domaines et ça nous fait ramener ça n'a
aucun sens écologique évidemment ce que
ça nous fait produire enfin ça nous rend
dépendant du gaz du charbon et on voit
totalement qu' on n'a pas su nous
imposer avec la vision qu'on peut avoir
que je parle de ce domaine précis mais
un petit peu dans beaucoup de domaines
pour défendre nos filières notamment la
filière agricole aussi qui nous est très
cher avec pierre frédéric billère ce
qu'on est tous les deux d'eure et loir
et il ya beaucoup de domaines comme ça
où la voix de la france s'est pas imposé
en tout cas les intérêts français ne se
sont pas imposés et on a pour essayer de
faire illusion cd dans beaucoup de
domaines il faudra que ça cesse et ça ce
sera si marine le pen évidemment
l'emportent en 2011 imposer la vision de
la france c'est ce que eric zemmour
finalement on va y parvenir parce que
lui sera à calais dans le même temps de
ce discours du président emmanuel macron
pierre frédéric billets cette question
de la souveraineté de la france
les a l'air bon la portée par la voix de
françois vous avez des belles années par
exemple est-ce qu'on va l'entendre
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée à strasbourg
oui on a une vision assez clair assez
claire des choses nous sommes nous
sommes européens mais nous sommes des
européens éclairé qui voulant garantit
une certaine indépendance de la france
par rapport aux enjeux et parfois la
volonté commune de certains pays de
pousser vers le fédéralisme c'est pas
notre vision des choses mais ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que le
président macron arrive à une présidence
de l'union européenne dans des
conditions difficiles bien sûr c'est la
crise sanitaire mais surtout c'est que
le bilan en démêler macron sur la
réforme des grandes réformes de notre
pays ces grands défendre n'ont pas été
réalisés on peut parler de la retraite
on peut parler d'un échange sur
l'économie et à ce titre là la france
n'est pas exemplaire au sein des pays de
l'union européenne dont qu'il arrive en
réalité assez fragilisé il pourra pas
trop faire la morale aux autres pays
parce que il peut faire la morale aux
français mais aux autres pays c'est
compliqué l'allemagne on écoute et on le
dit vous êtes gentil monsieur le
président mais il ya toute une série de
réformes sur lequel vous êtes engagé que
vous n'avez pas encore réalisé soyez
exemplaires montrer l'exemple et puis
peut-être que vous pourrez nous
expliquer qu'il faut pour essayer sur
l'immigration qu'il faut progresser sur
le social le culturel etc les priorités
définies par ml macron pour sa
présidence mais en réalité même s'il ya
une très belle communication autour le
président macron arrive très affaibli à
cette présidence alors on va parler de
l'autre titres de l'actualité politique
c'est évidemment les difficultés de jean
michel blanquer après son petit séjour a
émis sa qui a qui a créé pas mal de
mécontentement dans le monde de
l'enseignement qui va manifester à
nouveau demain voyez jean michel
blanquer il s'en est expliqué devant les
députés hier il y a je le reconnais une
symbolique il se trouve que le lieu que
j'ai choisi j'aurais dû en choisir sans
doute un autre la symbolique je la
regrette mais pour le reste madame la
députée depuis deux ans avec la majorité
avec mes équipes avec tous les
professeurs de france nous tenons la
politique de l'école ouverte c'est cela
qui est l'essentiel et nous nous perdons
pas dans l'accessoire alexander
nicholson entendu l'opposition
appelaient à la démission du istres est
ce que c'est votre avis
on doit pas se définir à jouer je vais
commenter ça changera pas grand chose
parce que ce qui est choquant delà de
ses vacances à ibiza gelés on l'avait
déjà répété c'est les errements qui a pu
avoir avec ces changements de protocole
ce qui est choquant quand même c'est que
des parents se sont adaptés certains ont
pris leur journée de travail le lundi
par exemple pour aller faire des tests
pcr parfois attendre des heures des
enseignants ont dû s'adapter et changer
ce subir des réflexions des parents le
lendemain quand il ya eu des annonces
avant même qu'ils soient prévenus parce
qu'ils ne savaient pas comment s'adapter
avec pas les attestations sur l'honneur
et tout ça c'est le bilan est donc on
est évidemment circonspect quand on voit
que les parents les enseignants ont pris
vraiment beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
ont subi beaucoup de pressions et
pendant ce temps là monsieur blanc caire
était à
ibiza et puis voilà assez surpris quand
on
fait de la politique et surtout dans la
période actuelle on peut se dire que
c'est pas le moment de prendre ce type
de vacances surtout quand on sait la
pression qui va y avoir à la rentrée je
suis surprise sur le calendrier je suis
surpris qu'ils les aient pas annulée en
termes de communication et même d'un
point de vue pratique parce que son
téléphone avait sonné tout le temps il
doit y avoir des adaptations en
permanente à mettre en place c'est pas
le meilleur emploi
il a travaillé pendant 4 euros davis a
en tout cas les les syndicats ont
rebaptisé ce protocole le protocole
elissa ça va être compliqué pour pour le
ministre pour la suite selon vous au
pire février
oui je crois que c'est une triple erreur
c'est une erreur vis-à-vis des
professeurs c'est une erreur vis-à-vis
des parents d'élèves et vis-à-vis des
élèves savez la grève de la semaine
dernière c'est assez historique par la
mobilisation et surtout c'est qu'on voit
que même les directions des
établissements scolaires ont fait la
grève même des inspecteurs ont fait la
grève c'est un signal d'alarmé assez
puissant alors maintenant on connaît les
vacheries entre collègues du
gouvernement donc on dit voilà on dit ce
qu'ils ont dit en plus il était à evisa
pour les vacances de noël bon ce
monsieur il a tout à fait le droit de
prendre des vacances
pourtant c'est pas le plus mauvais des
ministres il aurait dû sentir les choses
bizarres c'est un symbole qui est très
mauvais savez moi cet été je suis parti
en famille en corrèze c'est magnifique
la corrèze il devrait y aller c'est pas
loin de paris en plus voilà
c'est une grave erreur et moi je suis je
suis embêté pour l'attaqué monsieur
blanc clair parce que deux parmi tous
les ministres c'est pourtant un des mois
mauvais il combat le walkie ce message y
suis sensible et voilà on se retrouvait
le critiquer bon tout est compliqué on a
chamboulé la vie des élèves des
professeurs
il faut respecter ça il faudra leur côté
moi ça me rappelle castaner qui était en
boîte de nuit alors qu'il était ministre
n'intervient qui buvaient un coup avec
une collaboratrice tout ça tout ça n'est
pas très sérieux d'efforts on voit qu'il
ya un dérapage quand on est ministre on
est ministre à temps plein il faut faire
extrêmement attention à ce qu'on fait
tout symbolique est important surtout
dans les périodes de crise le problème
de l' exemplarité toujours on a entendu
le premier ministre jean castex hier
annoncé de nouvelles mesures pour les
restaurateurs pour le monde de
l'hôtellerie en général écoutez le
ministre est et on en parle après pour
les entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
qui sont affectés par les mesures et qui
perdrait non plus 50 mais 30% de leur
chiffre d'affaires sur les mois de
décembre et de janvier nous allons
mettre en place une aide exceptionnelle
au paiement de leurs cotisations
salariales d'un montant égal à 20 % de
leur masse salariale brute salaire +
charges avec son air nicoli tu sais ce
que c'est pour calmer les tensions quand
on sait qu'il ya cette manifestation
demain les restaurateurs qui ne veulent
pas appliquer les contrôles d'identité
du nouveau pass vaccinale à venir
comment est ce que vous y gcc nouvelles
mesures
mais c'est assez évident que
avant la présidentielle le gouvernement
essaie de distribuer un petit peu
d'argent pour calmer les tensions
pour essayer de toucher des filières des
secteurs
évidemment de manière électorale mais il
fallait y penser avant je dirai ce que
les mesures sont adaptées aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elles sont efficaces quand on
voit les taux de transmission et et
encore 400 mille personnes contaminées
hier on a vraiment le sentiment est ce
que les restaurateurs ont raison de
refuser de demander l'identité de leurs
clients
oui c'est pas leurs rollers je ne sais
pas des policiers c'est déjà difficile
ils subissent avec le pass vaccinale qui
aujourd'hui vraiment on peut
s'interroger d'ailleurs pour
l'équipement - on peut s'interroger sur
l'efficacité de ce pass se passe
vaccinale sur la transmission quand on
voit les chiffres or déjà eux mêmes
s'interrogent sur cette efficacité parce
qu'ils savent que ça leur fait perdre un
petit peu de clients on sait que ça
prend du temps déjà de demander le pass
vaccinale on sait que c'est compliqué au
quotidien cours eux et en plus on leur
demande une nouvelle fonction ça les
oblige parfois à recruter même parce que
on sait que déjà le personnel est
vraiment sous pression et que il ya déjà
peu de temps pour faire les autres
fonctions que celles qui peuvent
réaliser pour servir prendre les
commandes évidemment c'est pas leur rôle
et on est en train de leur mettre une
pression et leur faire diminuer leur
chiffre d'affaires donc l'heure où le
gouvernement essaie de s'adapter à ça en
distribuant un petit peu d'argent mais
fallait y penser avant est globalement
il faut penser avant à mettre des
mesures politiques pour dégager plus de
marge pour nos entreprises et les
restaurateurs c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué pour les restaurateurs
économiquement d'ailleurs on va en
parler longuement à 8 heures demain il
ya un nouveau conseil de défense est ce
qu'il faut aller vers des
assouplissements selon vous
oui bah savez c'est le pass vaccinale on
sent bien que par accident a été pris
parce que politiquement fallait le
prendre et qui a été embrigadé là dedans
donc il fallait le prendre dès le
passage sina le bon sens va pas faire
long feu on demande aux restaurateurs
c'est un contrôle d'identité alors là
c'est en mai on est dans la dans le
temps le stupide dans l'absurde parce
que même les policiers municipaux
peuvent pas faire d trop l'initiative
voilà exactement et des malheureusement
on sent bien qu'elle restaurateurs ont
une inquiétude entre aujourd'hui et le
mois d'avril sur la trésorerie sur
l'activité beaucoup sont sur le fil
rouge donc il faut prendre des mesures
un peu plus forte que ça vous
semble-t-il il faut les accompagner
parce qu'on a su les accompagner durant
la crise il faudrait pas qu'il ya deux
ou trois mois après il ferme les portes
quand l'activité va reprendre à plein là
il ya un point d'interrogation et moi
j'habite le gouvernement à revoir sa
copie sur l'aide aux restaurateurs c'est
très très urgent c'est à dire au revoir
sa copie en les aidant davantage enfin
c'est ce qu'il faut oui mais là là là
sur la baisse de 20% de la masse
salariale ou des gens comprennent
exactement ce que c'est mais tout
simplement c'est que les restaurateurs
ou un problème de trésorerie dans les
quatre mois qui viennent moi j'ai fait
pour des restaurateurs une dizaine de
restaurateurs il ya un gros point
d'interrogation
on les a beaucoup aidées il faut pas les
lâcher en rase campagne alors que a
priori mois d'avril on va voir la fin du
tunnel on verra cela en tout cas merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur
arte france